what are your thoughts about what's
going on right now with what they're
proposing with uh the new
gun laws well here's my thinking first
of all i don't think anyone at 18 years
old should be able to walk into a gun
shop and come out with a gun not at 18.
i i disagree with that you know they
talk about the military it's such a
silly comparison when you go into the
military they're training you how to use
the gun discipline authority they
they're giving you training on it not
letting you go out in the street and do
that so i think 18 is the wrong age i
wouldn't i wouldn't have no problem with
seeing it at 21 i have no problem with
background checks at all
i don't you know for me look patrick
here's here's what i said if they made
drunk if they make uh guns illegal the
only people that are gonna have guns are
those on the street the criminals i
could have gotten any gun i wanted
within 24 hours all i had to do was put
it out there anything that i wanted i
would have had when i was on the street
anything there's more illicit guns on
the street than you could imagine maybe
200 million
that's the numbers that are elicited
well illegal
yeah
200 million you can get them in a second
believe me so why would you take guns
out of legitimate people's hands that
are using them for the right reason and
maybe to defend themselves it makes no
sense so many things that these people
talk about make no sense but i am all
for
logical reform i don't think a kid at 18
should have a an m16 what are you gonna
do with it
why
you know no proper training at 18 most
guys are so immature anyhow at that
point in time so i like logical changes
you know to things that make sense and i
think most of american people think that
way too you know it's the same way look
you know roe versus wade is such a
hotbed people don't even understand
what's happening they're not saying it's
illegal they're saying it's it goes to
the state which it should have been in
the first place i agree with that it's
up to the states to decide if you have a
blue state and in that blue state people
think abortion is okay and they voted in
i'm against it i'm a pro-life guy but
hey you know what it should be in my
opinion the state should decide that if
you're in a red state and they say no
then
then there's no abortion you know
but look i was incensed i did a video on
it on my channel and uh when uh the
mayor of new york
gets out there i i can understand the
reasoning behind this and he said that
abortion should be legal right up to the
time of birth
and it's a health issue for the mother
now he didn't follow it up and say the
mother's health was at stake you know
her life was at stake and i don't care
what anybody says i mean my daughter i
have five daughters my youngest one was
born you know premature and now she's
the biggest out of all my kids and all
my daughters but i'm saying
that's a human life attached only by an
umbilical cord how can you say the
health of the mother is at risk it's
murder plain and simple but why would a
guy make a statement like this who is he
pandering to i don't think the normal
american per believes that so who is he
pandering to
a minority of people that that agree
with something like that no he's just
he's just pandering to the people that
are probably
funding or some people that he needs
their endorsement or some people that if
they piss him off
you know they may not get the support
wanting to be invited to those parties
because deep down inside he himself
knows that that doesn't makes i have to
believe that a logical reasonable person
has to believe that doesn't make any
sense to make a comment like that okay
it makes no sense yeah it's the same
thing i'll give you another example they
want to go soft on crime with criminals
right i spent eight years in prison and
20 years on the street do you think if
giuliani would have came to me and said
michael we're going to soften the
racketeering laws and we're going to
give you a bell if you get in trouble
don't worry about it do you think i
would have said oh you're such a nice
guy i'm going to go straight
i'm not going to commit crimes anymore i
would have said this guy losing his mind
it's open field
if you're lessening the the
consequences for a criminal they're
going to take advantage of it yeah so
what
i'm asking you patrick and you adam
you're intelligent guys because i can't
figure out what the reasoning is behind
this they're losing they have to be
losing most of the people that don't
agree with this people want to protect
themselves they want to be safe in their
neighborhoods
what is the reasoning behind people
acting like this and going soft on
criminals and really making you know the
innocent people the victims that but
they think they think that's what the
voters want so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]